yo what's up brandon and theo this is
mike from okc
see i got the authentic march on brandon
i know you call people out for that
uh you know i love watching ufc [ __ ]
fake fake merch
we just did the theo before the show and
then somehow mark from iowa had the same
yeah a lot of stolen valor out there
we should do some stolen balor episodes
sorry people are wearing faces
and fake [ __ ] man uh you know i love
watching the ufc
fights the heavyweight men go at it but
i got a king of stinger for you guys
when we gonna see them heavyweight women
go at it huh
i wanna know man we gotta see two 300
pound women duking it out
okay call donna tell them pay them girls
tell them they need a whole new weight
class a whole new belt okay
bigger belt okay heavyweight women going
at it call donna
tell them gang gang buzz buzz
peter man donna you know that i mean
there's just not a market
for it you know it's just what
are you telling me if we didn't start
those fights
right now there's not a marketplace
raise your hand if you'd watch it in
here no we all would okay
we all went well that's a mark now for
you for the king of the sting fight club
that we could definitely
you know call lizzo up to get partake in
the hell i want to see brittany griner
versus uh
who else who could she fight um
they're struggling to get 140 fighters
she's a thicker gal she could fight
britney grinder i think
i would like i would definitely like to
chelsea's athletic too i think she used
to skateboard herself man
huh some pride that that's that pride
style
then big boys or i'd watch uh
caitlyn jenner fight um brittany griner
that'd you really want to see her in the
octagon
usually yeah brittany grant is she
belonging lanky doug
is that your wife look everybody has to
you know we have to adapt
so overcome is that do you want a man
huh is that you wanna man i don't know
what her end goals are
[Laughter]
but she's a freaking legend yeah she
just had her sixth dunk i think the
other i'd love to see you get a shot off
against her
chris yeah dude i bet you couldn't even
nudge around her if you freaking had 10
minutes i bet you wouldn't even she
would freaking
bat every freaking thing you tried away
everything dude you're disgusting
yeah you're gross
i was talking to myself
[Music]